a long time ago in the very very present
humans and everything else coexisted
peacefully but he was in like the
bacteria and wanted to kill them all
and so they've used many different types
of beta-lactam antibiotics like
penicillin bacterial cell walls or maybe
peptidyl like monomers are crossing
together in a process catalyzed by
penicillin binding protein also known as
PvP the presence of penicillin
antibiotic
the reactive searing the center of PEP
will covalently bind to penicillin
this changes previous shape like any
protein the attenion shape changes its
function community can no longer cross
link the monomers a whole is left in the
cell wallet bacteria from which water
can enter the bacteria and drown here is
topi
tobey's bacteria naturally known as
human host but then antibiotics came as
people accepted the slaughter but soon
overuse led to a resistance he became
the infamous superbug mr saye who caused
a staph infection that potentially lead
to detrimental health concerns closing
him as a dangerous foe he all resolved
the beta-lactamase an enzyme that
hydrolyzes the beta-lactam antibiotics
to inactivate their powers that was just
any beta lactamase there's the ultimate
enzyme New Delhi metals beta lactamase
he strives to be like the interior
bacteria say superbugs resistant to the
strongest beta-lactam antibiotics
carbapenems
and he used this and lime to ruin them
to this day scientists are still trying
to figure out ways to defeat them so
what's our answer to superbugs at the
moment not much identify us continue to
become less effective interest in
studying antibiotics hasn't risen to
meet the demand to find a cure to
superbugs so what can you do at home to
help you to always try to naturally
fight off infections instead of rushing
to antibiotics you can also not foster
superbugs by not using antibacterial
products
you